[Música]
contra chico tan chico que no llegaba ni
a la tecla de la luz
pensaba que amigo era sinónimo de mate o
mi vecino que vivía a media cuadra de
casa con el practicante nos criamos
juntos y nunca hizo falta hacernos
amigos porque nuestra amistad era un
hecho más de la naturaleza como que el
cielo es azul o que eso que escuchábamos
en la radio a pilas en el medio de la
noche en el bosque eran señales
extraterrestres o de astronautas en
apuros y durante mucho tiempo pensé que
que no había otras personas allá fuera
además de mateo con las que yo pudiera
compartir mis intereses cuando empecé el
colegio mis compañeros me acercaban en
el recreo me hacían alguna pregunta yo
le respondía daba media vuelta y seguía
con lo mío la directora veía esto y le
pareció como que yo me escapaba cuando
las personas se me acercaban pero no lo
hacía a propósito en un momento se me
acercó la directora que además era mi
mamá y me explicó que a veces las
personas nos hacen preguntas no tanto
porque quieren saber la respuesta sino
porque quieren conversar
a esa altura será bastante obvio que
había muchas cosas que yo no entendía
cómo funcionaban por ejemplo cuando mis
vecinos más grandes jugaban a las
escondidas yo iba y les marcaba uno por
uno donde se habían escondido entonces
se enojaban y se quejaban y yo explicaba
que se les había escondido
otros estaban buscando y yo sabía dónde
se habían escondido porque no podía ir
contarles dónde estaba y resolver toda
la situación
o en los cumpleaños yo llevaba el regalo
y justo antes de entregarlo lo abría y
explicaba de qué se trataba
dónde lo habíamos comprado cuánto había
salido y si estaba o no de oferta
me costaba horrores no salir corriendo a
contarle a todo el mundo cada vez que
aprendía algo nuevo
y lo que me pasaba en esa situación
también es que me daba cuenta de que a
veces a las personas el mundo se nos
hace demasiado complejo y quizás no nos
preguntamos lo suficiente
hace ya algún tiempo que me doy cuenta
de que cuando me explican algo social
una cosa social la puedo desarmar como
si fuera una cosa de las que tenemos a
nuestro alrededor con cables y tornillos
y tuercas pero que por ejemplo cómo
funcionan los cumpleaños o cómo
funcionan hacer amigos o cómo funciona
jugar a las escondidas son cosas que
también se puede entender cuando las
abrimos y por eso es que ya desde
bastante tiempo que cuando me preguntan
de qué trabajo cuento que me dedico a
entender cómo funcionan las cosas es una
respuesta un poco pretenciosa entonces
algunas personas piensan que me dedico a
esto porque tengo una sordina suerte de
experto en cosas que una peculiar
capacidad para entender cómo es que
funcionando lo cierto es que si me
dedico a esto es porque me cuesta mucho
pero mucho entender qué demonios pasa a
mi alrededor
y eso siempre me hizo sentir una especie
de raro porque me daba cuenta de
que no solo hacía muchas preguntas y más
que las personas a mi alrededor sino que
por ahora mis preguntas eran distintas y
así por ejemplo aprendí que cuando
alguien dice me muero de hambre no hace
falta llamar una ambulancia o que cuando
alguien nos cuenta que se le murió a un
familiar lo mejor no es alegrarnos
incluso si esa persona ahora va a tener
más tiempo libre
y haciendo muchas plantas también me di
cuenta que las personas por lo general
no se preguntan acerca de las cosas más
normales de las cuestiones cotidianas
por ejemplo
porque nos saludamos con un beso y nos
damos la mano al menos solíamos hacer
eso o porque a veces las personas nos
preguntan cómo estás aunque no les
interesa realmente nuestra respuesta o
por qué las personas compran y llevan
ramos de las estructuras reproductivas
características de las plantas
espermatozoides flores y se las dan a
una persona que no se siente bien o como
una forma de seducción de la persona que
les gusta
y cuando hace muchas preguntas también
te das cuenta que a veces a las personas
no les cae muy bien entonces algunas se
enojan porque quizás se dan cuenta de
que nunca habían pensado en algunas
cosas y hay otras que se frustran porque
se dan cuenta de que quizás no sabían
tanto ni entendían tanto como creían
no tengo un truco especial para hacerme
muchas preguntas lo único que hago es
prestar atención en particular a la voz
de mi curiosidad que es esa vocecita que
cuando somos chicos nos atosiga con
preguntas que es la que nos invita a
preguntar y por qué y por qué cada dos
preguntas y es esa que a medida que
vamos creciendo nos vamos acostumbrando
a ignorar
a veces porque no encontramos a quien
hacerle alguna pregunta y a veces porque
después de preguntar mucho la otra
persona se cansa y nos dice porque sí y
nos manda a jugar el patio no olvidemos
que algunas personas logran ignorar su
vocecita y seguir sus vidas si nunca
levantarse a las dos de la mañana para
buscar algo en internet pero algunas
otras personas nuestra voz es tan
insistente que si la tratamos de callar
llora y patalea toda la noche y no nos
deja dormir la forma que yo encontré
para hacer las paces con la voz de mi
curiosidad es justamente prestarle mucha
atención y desde hace tres años y medio
que lo que hago es no solo perseguir mi
curiosidad sino documentarlo una vez por
semana
todos los domingos a la mañana envío por
correo electrónico a un texto breve
acerca de cómo funciona una cosa
distinta y lo que hago es fijarme que
dijo la ciencia la filosofía la historia
o la literatura acerca de algo que haya
llamado mi atención durante la semana
por ejemplo escribí acerca de cómo
funciona los bolsillos
a veces no son más que un mero reflejo
de la manera en que la misoginia o el
sexismo toma la forma de diminutos
bolsillitos que no sirven para nada o
cómo funciona tener una identidad
secreta que nos permite explicar por qué
a veces cuando nos ponemos unos anteojos
o un buzo o incluso una capa nos podemos
sentir más seguros de quiénes somos o es
lo que permite explicar por qué nunca
nos vieron a batman ya mí en el mismo
lugar
cómo funciona bostezar qué es un
comportamiento involuntario que traemos
en nuestra historia evolutiva desde hace
muchísimo muchísimo tiempo que
practicante nos conecta con todo el
resto de vertebrados en el planeta
tierra o en otras palabras es la
respuesta a la pregunta que nunca nadie
se hizo respecto de qué tienen en común
una lagartija un pingüino y brad pitt
y así yo llevo 150 correos escritos un
poco más pero sobre lo que más me gusta
escribir es acerca de esas cosas que son
absolutamente cotidianas y de las cuales
las personas nunca ni siquiera se les
ocurre buscar nada al respecto cosas
como mirar a los ojos o dar un abrazo o
darle un beso o
agarrarle la mano a la persona que te
gusta o empezar una conversación o
incluso hacer nuevos amigos y durante
mucho tiempo pensé que todo el mundo
entendía cómo funcionaban esas cosas y
que el día que lo habían explicado yo me
había quedado en casa con varicela pero
ahora que soy más grande y más pillo me
doy cuenta de que en realidad la mayoría
de las personas no nos entienden muy
bien cómo funcionan las cosas y no sólo
eso sino que muchas veces ni siquiera se
hacen muchas preguntas quizás es porque
da un poco de alergia hacer tantas
preguntas o quizás es porque nos
acostumbramos a que dispersarse y
perseguir nuestra curiosidad está mal y
que es mejor saber más de menos y menos
que saber más de más y más
y lo que aprendí también es que algunas
personas solo necesitan un empujoncito
para empezar a hacerse preguntas y
detenerse en las cosas que les llamaron
la atención durante la semana eso sí no
deja de ser especialmente extraño estar
acá hablando acerca de la curiosidad o
de hacerse muchas preguntas y algo
interesante es que cuando empecé a
escribir lo hice porque me sentía un
poco solo porque puede ser un poco
solitario hacernos muchas preguntas y
tratar de buscar esas respuestas y luego
querer compartirlo con el mundo pero lo
que encontré es que somos un montón de
bichos raros y que hay miles de personas
que leen que cuando su curiosidad no les
deja dormir la invitan a un pijama party
y nada de esto debería sonar nos
novedoso porque de hecho haciéndonos
preguntas es que surgió la filosofía o
la ciencia o incluso la poesía y es en
la búsqueda de las respuestas en las
distintas disciplinas que no encontramos
más que poesía y alguien me podría decir
bueno muy bien pero la curiosidad no
sirve para nada porque si lo que
queremos es tener un mejor trabajo
o ganar una beca o aprobar una materia
lo que más nos conviene es enfocarnos lo
más posible y dispersarlos lo menos
posible y eso es absolutamente cierto
pero al mismo tiempo si nos fijamos de
dónde vienen las buenas ideas lo que
encontramos es que vienen de unir cosas
que estaban muy distantes entre sí y
cuya relación ni se nos ocurría y que
tampoco eran tan obvias y es por eso que
si no nos hacemos preguntas nuestro
mundo se hace cada vez más chiquitito y
eso es especialmente trágico
sobre todo porque también si nos
detenemos a pensar un poco somos la
única especie que tiene esta capacidad
de pensarse a sí misma y de pensarse en
relación al universo y en las respuestas
maravillarse por eso es que además de
todo tenemos cierto deber moral de
asombrarnos
y en esta eterna búsqueda de no solo las
cosas que nos llama la atención sino
también de sentirnos menos solos quizás
la respuesta está también en estas en
esas instancias en que en el recreo a
alguien se me acercaba a hacer alguna
pregunta y yo me daba media vuelta y me
iba y quizás la respuesta es justamente
que cuando nos preguntan algo seguir
haciendo las preguntas y la clave no sea
más que esa nunca dejar de hacernos
preguntas
[Música]